[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANDY CHANG: Hi, everyone.
So welcome to SEC102 around the
Cloud Security Command Center
and also thank you for spending
the last part of your day
with us.
We recognize we're standing
between you and drinks,
so we'll hopefully
keep this interesting.
I'm Andy Chang.
I'm product manager at
Google Security Team
and also the product manager
for the Cloud Security Command
Center.
I'm joined here on stage with
both partners and customers,
and so I'm going to turn it
over to some of the other folks.
MICHAEL CAPICOTTO:
I'm Michael Capicotto.
I'm a cloud security
architect at Two Sigma.
KAMILLA AMIROVA: Hi, everyone.
I'm Kamillah Amirova.
I'm a solutions engineer
and special projects team
at Cloudflare.
FRANCESCO VIGO: And
I'm Francesco Vigo
from Palo Alto Networks.
I am a solution architect
on technical integrations.
ANDY CHANG: And
each of those folks
will be coming back on stage
to talk to their parts,
and so we're going
to kick it off now.
So our goal today is to
really do four things--
talk to you about what an
overview of the Cloud Security
Command Center is--
it's a project we launched to
public alpha back in March--
and give you an update on
where we are with that.
Also, to provide
with Michael's help,
an example of how Two Sigma is
leveraging the Cloud Security
Command Center on their
production systems.
And then with two of
our partners, Cloudflare
and Palo Alto
Networks, how they're
integrating with Cloud
Security Command Center
and providing
additional visibility
into customers' signals,
networking, network traffic,
DOS, and WAF.
And then I'll summarize.
So, with the Cloud
Security Command Center,
our goal really is to provide
that canonical place in GCP
for you to bring all
the things together
that you care about when you
think about security, risk,
and privacy.
So it's really where we're
bringing together your assets
from an inventory standpoint,
the detections that you have,
the findings, the policies
that you're running,
the underlying
annotations that you
want to put specially
on the resources,
bring that together so you
have a unified view of that,
whether those signals
come from Google products,
from third-party products,
from your own detectors.
And our goal really is to kind
of give back to you visibility
and control so that
you have the ability
to look at your attack surface.
So some of the key things
that, from a functionality
standpoint, the purpose of the
Cloud Security Command Center
is really to gather
and integrate
all of that information
at an organization level
so you get to look across
different projects and services
as you're running.
To allow you, as we said,
to understand and analyze
that information, to
act on that information,
and really to be a hub for
a range of Google security
products all in one place.
And we recognize that we're
not the only player that you're
going to have, especially if
you're in a hybrid situation,
so our goal has been to design
this product and this platform
as API first so you can
as well egress and export
this information to your own
systems for further analysis.
When we think about the general
kind of attacker or defender
kill chain-- and we
see here the attacker
kill chain popularized by
Lockheed Martin in 2011.
At Google, we also think
about a defender kill chain,
and for the defender
kill chain side,
we think about two
phases of that--
being proactive
in a pre-fail mode
so that you have an
assessment of really what
your overall attack surface
is, what you care about,
what you should be focused
on, and what matters to you.
To really be able
to specify ahead
of time what are the policies,
what are the configurations
that you want to
run, and also to be
able to then monitor the
drift against those and also
deploy protections--
things that will
by design enable
you to kind of
prevent certain types
of attacks and vulnerabilities.
We also then think about
what happens in post-fail--
when monitoring and logging
turn into detection.
So the key signals that
you find are the ones
that you're going to
operate on when you're
investigating an incident.
Obviously alerting
on those things
so that your teams-- your
incident response teams
can act on those and your
SOC can act on those.
To be able to
actually then respond,
whether it's in a full
fix or a mitigation.
To then be able to manage your
communications across those.
And also, very
importantly, to learn--
and that's learn from
a process standpoint,
from a people standpoint, as
well from a machine learning
technology standpoint.
The Cloud Security
Command Center in v1
is focused on the first
half of this chain--
being able to enable you
to do a much better job
of proactive protection
by giving you
the visibility on those
assets and those findings.
When we think about how
this plays in context,
this is a framework
that we look at when
we think about helping our
customers become more secure.
So at a high level, we
think about the risks
that you're looking at
really in five categories.
They're really securing
the underlying inventory--
and that's the inventory
of hardware and software
you're running in your systems--
securing the data-- that's
data that either you've created
or data that you've captured
from your end customers--
securing the
configurations so that each
of the services you start off
in is in a best practice known
good state and understanding
the drift against that,
securing your identity
and management design
so that you have the proper
amount of access and control
to the different
permissions and policies,
and then helping you secure
the applications that you build
on our own infrastructure.
So matching that
are the capabilities
we're building into the Cloud
Security Command Center, which
we'll demo in a few minutes.
First is the asset
inventory to give you
that view of both
the current state
and historical state of assets.
The ability to track when
the assets have changed
and how they've been
modified and to really
manage those assets and group
them in business-relevant ways
beyond just what's in
the resource hierarchy.
In addition, one
of the core things
and what will be exciting
to hear from both Two Sigma,
Cloudflare, and Palo Alto,
is bringing in signals
in to findings that matter
to customers in one place
so they can make
decisions on that.
And then the ability really
to provide you as a customer
the ability to create
filters and queries
to find the specific
data that you want.
Obviously the visibility side
is one part and then the action
part is the other, so the
ability to mark things so that
you can group them by
priority, the ability to create
notifications through a Sidecar
application that we ship with
the product, the ability as well
to do mitigation remediations--
again through a Sidecar
connection to cloud functions--
and then finally, to be
that hub for the security
products like our Anomaly
Detector, our Web Security
Scanner, and our DOP technology.
So what you'll see in
the demo forthcoming
is really the UI part
of the Command Center.
That UI really has
three main surfaces.
The first is the
Dashboard, which is really
the overall view of what's
going on in your system
and gives you an ability
to understand and look
at what's hot, what's happening,
what you should focus on.
And then where we see
analysts and security
professionals spend
most of their time
is in the inventories.
We have an Asset
Inventory so that you
can take an asset-centric
view of what's
going on in your system,
as well as a Findings
Inventory that you can take
a finding-centric view,
and they both
cross-leverage each other.
And then finally, for
any entity that we've
indexed, whether it's an asset,
a resource, or a finding,
we have the ability to
drill in at a detail level
so you can look like the
underlying properties.
So without further
ado, I'm going
to switch over to the demo.
So what you're seeing here
now is the live version
of the Cloud Security
Command Center.
It basically is an organization
that we've created.
That organization has
a bunch of assets--
routes, subnetworks, firewalls,
buckets, instances, disks.
You can look at it
historically, so we can see
what changed seven days ago.
So over the last seven days,
we've added a bunch of routes,
we've deleted one of
the unknown things,
we've looked at the firewalls,
we've gone and looked
at the overall disk pieces.
We go back, say, three
months, and you'll
see that the system has
even changed more radically
over that period of time.
And this gives you kind of
an ongoing record time series
of how your assets data is.
In addition, we have
the findings side
of the world, which is looking
at the various signals that
are integrated in to tell
you what we've collected
around either good, bad findings
for each of the underlying
assets.
So first is an overall
findings summary card,
which takes a look at what
are the different detectors
and what have they surfaced,
and then we start with three
of the Google detectors.
So we have a Cloud
Anomaly Detector
that allows you on a
VM basis to understand
when we think there is a
hijacking going on, when there
potentially coin mining,
data exfiltration,
potentially if your VM
has been compromised
and being used in a DOS net.
If your VM has been compromised
and it's being used to try to
intrude on other systems.
In addition, we have our
Web Security Scanner which
is available in
GA and App Engine
and is in Public
Alpha for GCE and GKE,
and that lets you find things
like cross-site scripting
vulnerabilities, outdated
libraries, mixed content.
You can run that on your
publicly-facing applications
and those results automatically
surface in the Command Center
when there are findings.
In addition, we're integrated
with the DLP technology
that we announced, I think,
more than a year ago at Next,
which allows you to scan
all of your public buckets
and scan all your buckets in
your system and then classifies
whether there is PII
found in those buckets.
And that gives you a
sense of the surface area
and the blast radius of
when things potentially
are compromised,
where your data is,
what data is highly sensitive.
In addition, we're
integrated with Forseti.
So Forseti is Google's
open-source effort
to build a security
community around GCP
and has a set of scanners that
both Google has contributed
as well as our partners
and community members
and Forseti have contributed,
which those results also index
and can be surfaced
in Command Center.
And then we have a range
of partner integrations.
From the container security
side, Cloudflare, which Kamilla
will talk about in more detail.
Folks like CrowdStrike,
Dome9, Palo Alto Networks,
which Francesco will talk
about in more detail.
Qualys, RedLock, Sysdig,
StackRox, and Twistlock.
So that gives you a sense
of-- and this would obviously
be a really unhappy system
if all of these bad thigs
were happening to it.
So, as I said,
this is that place
where customers go on a daily
basis to see what's going on,
and then if they want
to go investigate,
they would dig into something
like the Asset Inventory.
So the structure of
the Asset Inventory
is one that, first,
you can slice
your data based on
either the projects
or the underlying assets.
And as we said, we cover App
Engine, GCE, GKE, GCR docker
images, and then GCS from a
bucket standpoint currently,
and we'll be continuously adding
more of the Google services.
You can take that view
of either-- for example,
I want to look at
all my buckets.
You can just truncate on that.
Or instead, if I wanted to
go to a particular project--
and let's say I want to
go to this dev project
and then I wanted to look
at just all the buckets that
are in that, so
I would basically
select Attribute Asset
Type, type Buckets,
and then this filters
down to just the buckets
within that project.
So the way we've
constructed this
is what you select on the left
in the kind of overall resource
hierarchy.
On the right, you
get only the assets
that belong to that
resource hierarchy,
and you can further
filter things.
So one of the things
that we can look
for which people care
about is, you know,
what if I expose one
of my buckets publicly?
How would I find that?
So first, I would look-- again,
I'd go across my organization.
I'd want to go ahead and
search again for my buckets.
And then once I've
searched for my buckets,
I'd want to look at
one of the properties
and that would be
the ACL property,
and let's say if I have an All
Authenticated Users on that.
And sure enough, we have one
bucket we've exposed to public.
Right?
So what does that mean?
We can dig into that
a little bit more.
That bucket basically
has a set of attributes,
a set of detail
properties specific to it.
You can see right here that
the All Authenticated Users has
been set up as a reader, so if
that's intended, that's great,
but if that's a bucket with
highly sensitive information,
that would be bad and you'd
want to remediate that.
The other thing that we
want to cover a little bit
is from a time standpoint.
So if we go back to this
demo, this changed at about--
let's see, last scan at 3:58.
So if we were to look
back at yesterday--
and we can go back
to yesterday--
we can figure out whether
this bucket was actually
public yesterday or not.
So as of yesterday, it
wasn't, so it happened
some time between now and then.
And we can look
at, then, the logs
to figure out when
that occurred.
In addition, from an
asset inventory side,
we can also slice things
based on findings.
So from the findings,
first you see
you have, again, two choices.
You can see things either listed
by all the possible findings
or you can sort them by
the particular source type.
And so we have findings from
each of the underlying sources.
If we were to dig
into a finding-- let's
say our own Anomaly
Detector, we could
find and dig into the
VM that has coin mining.
And what that ends up telling
again on our Detail page
is what action should be
taken against that, what it's
against, that it's
an active finding,
and an underlying summary
of what's going on.
For third parties, like
Cloudflare or Palo Alto,
when we have an
integration there,
they surface their
findings as a summary.
Just like any other finding,
you can drill into that finding.
They provide underlying detail.
And then you can connect
back to the partner console.
So go back into the Cloudflare
system, in this example,
look at that particular
website that's involved,
and then dig into the
underlying data there as well.
So that's the kind
of integrations
that we have with the
underlying providers.
So to wrap up this
part of the demo,
and what we've
covered today really
is some of the
underlying capabilities
for filtering and searching.
One last thing we
have the ability
to do is for you
to create marks,
and what those marks allow
you to do is to group data
by things that matter.
So for example, I created a mark
previously around an incident
and I care about all the
different findings that
are relative to that incident.
So I've already pre-marked them
so that becomes these eight
or nine findings, and
similarly, on the asset side,
I've also put that mark together
on some of the assets that
are relevant to this.
And so as we go ahead and then
put the same incident number
in, it pre-filters
down to those,
and then I can go
in the Dashboard
and again look and see
just for the assets that
are relevant to that incident
as well as the findings that
are relevant to that incident.
So with this, I'm going to
switch back to the slides.
And so what we covered there
was the Asset Inventory,
the Findings, the ability
to filter and search,
the ability to use the marks,
and also the integrations
with a range of our partners.
What we now want
to talk about is,
as one of the core parts in
the differentiation for Command
Center is the ability to
integrate all those findings,
so we're going to dig
a little bit deeper
into what that means,
what findings are,
what finding sources are.
So for us, we've defined
findings very broadly.
They really are an
output from a source,
and it could be
a curated output,
it could be a raw output,
that then applies to an asset
that we've indexed or a
resource that we've indexed
and it allows us to
build that connection
to do either a finding-centric
view of the world
or an asset-centric
view of the world.
And it's valid for
a particular time
or between two time
points, so that
allows us to tie that into
its history and its lifecycle.
And they need to have a unique
ID because we automatically
dedupe findings within
the Command Center,
so if you have the same
finding six or seven times,
it doesn't show up as
six or seven findings.
It shows up as the same
finding and it just
updates its properties and
its time stamp as it goes.
And so that allows things to
be correctly indexed and joined
in the Command Center database.
When we think about findings,
they come from finding sources,
and our mental model so
far for finding sources
is really around the ability
to think of three main types--
scanners, which really provide
you essentially a snapshot
in time of the state
of your whole system
or the state between
two time points,
and what that allows
us to do is to say
that represents the
kind of complete state
that we want to integrate
in and see what's
going on for that time stamp.
Examples of scanners are the
Cloud Security Scanner that
we've integrated within Google,
the DLP scanner as well--
they both scan the state of
either an application or a set
of buckets at a point in time--
the standard L3L4
network scanners
that are scanning
ports, because again,
if they have an overall
scan across a set of ports,
they have underlying results.
Things from the container
image scanners from folks
like Twistlock.
And the second type
of finding source
that we integrate
with are monitors,
and so those are things
that produce event streams.
So the common
example of that are
agents that are put into
either VMs or into containers
and they prevent
basically a stream
of events with no history
back to the system.
And the third type of source
that we can integrate with
are really loggers.
So that's the canonical
log file ingestion,
where that's a series
and historical record
of a series of events that
get adjusted and processed.
So if you as a customer or you
as a partner have one or more
of these types, these
are types that we
can integrate in and have
their results join together
with the rest of the findings in
Cloud Security Command Center.
Think a little bit more
about how that happens.
What we show here is a
screenshot of our alpha API.
It's a little hard to read.
There's a link directly to
our documentation, which
is a public documentation of
how you use the Create Findings
API.
The key thing is
that there are really
seven things that
you need to provide
as someone who wants to write
results to our Command Center.
The first, as we talked
about, is that unique ID
so that we can do
our own deduping.
The second is the
actual insight that you
want to surface in Command
Center, both in the dashboard
and as kind of the key title
in indexing for the Findings
Inventory.
The third thing is the mapping
to the one or more Google Cloud
assets that these
findings apply to
and the fourth thing
is a time stamp.
So as we are a
historical record,
we're able to put
that finding in place
relative to the other
things in our time database.
And then lastly, the
link back to-- if you're
a commercial vendor,
your own portal,
because our goal and our
philosophy with integration
is to really surface the
key things that we think
are relevant to the customer,
but if they want to go in deep
and dive in more
detail, we fully
expect that they'd want to
go into your own dashboard
and explore those using the
tools that you've invested in.
So that linkage, as we showed
with the Cloudflare example,
provides that two-way
kind of transition.
And then lastly,
the key thing to add
is finding specific properties.
So when you surface a finding on
your side as either a customer
or as a partner,
identifying the key items
that you want the end
customer to see that
will drive them
to an action that
will help them get to
a more secure space.
What partners get from
integrating with the Cloud
Security Command Center
and what they gain
are really showing up
in four key places.
First, in the Summary
on the Dashboard,
as we saw with each of
the dashboard cards.
Second, in the inventories,
both actually in the Findings
Inventory and in the Asset
Inventory because the assets
can index into the findings,
into the specific Detail
pages which allow the
customer to drive action,
and then actually into
our Datacube Index, which
is our back-end database which
allows you to search, select,
and find API and Views.
If we think about integration,
there's really three options
if you're a customer
or a partner of how
you can integrate data into the
Cloud Security Command Center.
The first option assumes that
you have a presence in GCP
itself, and so in this
model, as a customer,
the customer has an
organization in GCP,
you have an organization in GCP.
The first step is for
you to essentially scan
the customer's instance or
instances or organizations
so that you find
out what's going on.
The second is to spin
up a connector project
in your own organization,
which will end up
being the intermediary
between your overall back-end
and our Cloud Security
Command Center.
The third is to do then
the authorization so
that your service
account for your project
is authorized to write
to the Security Command
Center for the
customers, as well
as you do your own
authorizations,
your own back-end,
to uniquely identify
the customer's information
that you want to send.
And then to push the
data from your back-end
into the Cloud Security Command
Center via that connector
project.
The second option is if you're
not running on GCP at all
is to instantiate
your connector project
after you do the scanning in
the customer's organization.
So to provide the
basic underlying
code that allows the customer to
stand up that connection point.
Again, authorization both
towards us and the customer's
Cloud Security Command Center
as well as to your own back-end
so the right data
gets the right place
and then connecting the
data through and through.
And the third option is if you
are not running anything on GCP
and you have completely partner
back-end is again to first scan
the customer's organization
for the results that you want
to run, and then through
the customer, authenticate--
allow them to authenticate
into your system--
provide a nice API
key that gives them
access to the Command Center,
and once that API is installed
on your back-end, you can then
write to the Security Command
Center specific to
that organization.
So those are the three methods.
We've had customers and partners
use each of these three methods
to do integration.
And if you want to find
out more information,
please find me after the talk.
So to summarize the kind
of first part of the Cloud
Security Command Center
is, at the end of the day,
the goal is to
integrate in one place
and unify our assets,
resources, and findings.
If you want to integrate your
findings in the Command Center,
our partner model is really
set up in three stages.
First, a scenario definition
between the product managers
so that collectively we're
looking at the end customer's
journey so that the
right set of data
gets surfaced in Command
Center and the right pull
and kind of pull through
occurs to drive them back
to your own console.
Prototyping so that we build
an example first within a demo
organization that us
and the partner manage,
and then find a lead
customer to kind of go deploy
that live with, and then
finally, the execution
deployment at scale for general
availability for customers.
So with that, I've
kind of given you
an overview of both the
capabilities of the Cloud
Command Center as
well as how partners
integrate with Command Center.
What I'd like to do now
is to turn this over
to Michael Capicotto
from Two Sigma
to talk to you a little about
how they've used Cloud Security
Command Center.
MICHAEL CAPICOTTO: So my
name's Michael Capicotto.
I'm a cloud security
architect at Two Sigma,
and I kind of
wanted to introduce
who Two Sigma is, what we do,
and a little bit about how
we approach cloud
security before I show you
what we're doing with the
Security Command Center.
So Two Sigma is a New York
City-based hedge fund.
We use things like artificial
intelligence, machine learning,
distributed computing-- all of
kind of the latest technologies
to drive our
investment strategy.
And for that reason,
operating in the public cloud
has been extremely
important to us
so that we can scale up and
scale down very dynamically.
To give you an example,
we use something
like 35 petabytes of data to
build our investment models,
and this is a growing
number, and so
one of the primary concerns
we have in cloud security
is really protecting
against data exfiltration.
So all of the code and data
that we write and generate,
it's very important for us to
protect against this leaking,
right?
That's our job.
So that's the approach we take.
And we really think about
it in three ways, right?
We use defense and depth so
that we have a layered approach
to security.
If we kind of make a
mistake in one area,
we can fall back on other areas.
We use automation
very heavily, right?
As the public cloud has moved--
I guess as we've moved
into the public cloud,
we've seen things scale
up a lot quicker, right?
People can procure VMs in
a few seconds as opposed
to, like, a few months,
and so obviously the attack
surface scales very
quickly and this means
that we have to react quickly.
So we use automation from
a security perspective
for things like secure approval
and deployment pipelines-- very
repeatable security processes.
And then of course there is,
like, the continuous audit
piece and that's
extremely important to us,
because even though you
set up your environment
in a secure manner on day
one, six months later or two
years later, it's
going to drift, right?
The configuration and the
environment's going to change,
and so you want to have
some sort of system that's
continuously auditing
your environment
to kind of have control
over what's going on
and to react to any changes.
So just to talk a little bit
more about defense in depth,
if you think all the way
up at a very high level,
you have your
organization and GCP,
and you can apply something
like an organization policy.
What this does, just
to give you an example,
is it's really like
a blanket security
control on your whole org.
So one example of how we
use that is we build, like,
a secure image-- say a
secure Debian image--
with all of the
security controls
and OS hardening
kind of mechanisms
that we use, and then we
apply an org policy that
says, in any of the folders or
projects that Two Sigma has,
we want users to
only be spinning up
VMs from that secure image.
Right?
So that's kind of all the
way at the top of the stack.
Bubbling down a little bit
into the individual folders
and projects, we create
custom IM roles for our users
and groups, and we do this based
on a least permissive model,
right?
So only the kind of
minimum set of permissions
those users need to
operate successfully
in their environment.
We create a custom role
and assign it to them.
Things like VPC
Security Controls
to kind of draw
a secure boundary
around all of our resources.
And then all the way down to
the individual resource level.
So if you think about
like BigQuery data sets,
you can have access control
lists on those actual data
sets.
Another example is a
GCS bucket, which I'm
going to be using in the demo.
So those both have concept of
access control lists and you
can control the security at
the individual resource level.
Right?
And then speaking a little
bit more about the automation
we use, there are some, I
guess, unexpected consequences
of using certain GCP APIs.
So to give you an
example of that,
if you authorize your users to
create a data set in BigQuery,
when they create that
data set, they actually
become the owner on the data
set access control list.
And the consequence of that
is they can turn around
and share that data
set, even with users
outside your organization.
Right?
So for us, this is
like a huge shock
because we're trying to
prevent data leakage,
and obviously we can't
have sensitive data loaded
into a data set and
then just any user
can share that with the world.
So an example of how we use
automation to fix that is we've
actually written a
server list cloud
function that creates data
sets on behalf of users.
And so they call that cloud
function, the cloud function
creates the data set, and it
strips all of the owners out
of the ACL, kind of
fixes it up, and then
it returns back to the user, you
know, here's your new data set.
You can use it at this link.
And really the last piece
is, even though we've
taken an approach that
uses defense in depth,
that uses automation,
that's really
kind of the day one
setup of the environment
and it drifts over time.
So we use in conjunction
Cloud Security Command
Center and Forseti really
to monitor our environment,
to audit and ensure that those
security guard rails are still
in place, and then to surface
any violations of that to us.
So I'm just curious,
show of hands,
how many people are
familiar with Forseti?
Awesome.
Cool.
OK, so Two Sigma is a
contributor to Forseti,
and I encourage you guys
to become contributors
if you're interested, but
working with the Cloud Security
Command Center and Forseti teams
has been extremely positive.
They've been super
helpful and we've
been able to contribute
some codes to Forseti
and to get that merged
into the latest branch,
so I'll talk a little
bit about that later.
But for those of you who
haven't used Forseti or heard
or Forseti, it's
really a tool that
lets you scan your
environment and you
can write very simple
rule sets in YAML format.
As an example, if we keep
using this BigQuery example,
you could write a rule that says
I don't want any @twosigma.com
users in my data set ACL ever.
And Forseti will
run periodically,
it will scan through
all of your data sets,
and it will find
violations of that rule.
And you can surface
those in various ways.
You can get an
email to yourself.
I know they're building
out integration
with Pub/Sub and Slack.
But of course we use Cloud
Security Command Center
as kind of our
central pane of glass,
and so we wanted to surface
commands into there,
and that's possible
today with Forseti.
There is integration
between the two.
So let me walk you through
a little bit of an example.
This is kind of what
I'm going to demo,
but I just wanted to show
you guys what happens first.
Right?
So it's very similar to
the BigQuery example.
So let's say you
have a user, Bob.
He joins your company and
he wants to create a bucket.
So he's going install the
Google Command Line Utility
and he's going to make a simple
API call to create that bucket.
And the unintended consequence
of this is in the back-end.
The data set has an
access control list,
and Bob just became
owner on that bucket
and he can now share it, right?
And if you're trying to
protect buckets and make sure
that they don't get shared
outside of your organization,
this is kind of an
undesirable effect, right?
So bucket owner equals Bob.
Owners can share.
I kind of already
explained that.
This opens up a very easy
path for data leakage.
So what we would do--
I guess, if we were
thinking about things
from a very manual perspective,
as a diligent security team,
we would want to go modify
the ACL on that bucket, right?
And of course there's like
an API call to do that,
so we could install the
Command Line Utility
and say I want to change
the ACL on the bucket
and I want to set Bob to be
an editor and not an owner.
But you can imagine that
as your organization scales
and there's hundreds or
thousands or tens of thousands
of users all creating
buckets, you're
not going to hire 100
people on your security team
to constantly go change the ACL
on all of the buckets, right?
So what you would probably
do in that scenario
is you would abstract it
away with a cloud function
or something like that,
like I explained before,
but that's kind of
only the initial setup.
That means that when
the bucket gets created,
you're going to remove
unintended owners from the ACL.
It doesn't mean that it's
going to stay that way forever,
right?
And there's always
going to be, like,
super users in your
organization that
can go and make changes, whether
maliciously or just by mistake.
So this is where Cloud Security
Command Center really helps us.
Andy talked a little bit
about the security marks
that you can apply.
So we use these in a
bit of a different way.
We mark resources in
Security Command Center
with a security level, right?
So it could be like open,
internal, restricted, super,
super restricted.
And what we do is we use
these marks to differentiate
resources and we
can apply scanning
to only certain classes of
resources that we care about.
So let's, like, just
walk through that, right?
What we would do, rather
than creating buckets
on behalf of the users, is
we would create that security
mark, and in this case,
we're just saying the buckets
that we care about are
restricted-- they have
a security level of restricted.
And now let's say that
someone makes a mistake
and they add Alice as an
owner on that bucket ACL.
We have some very simple code
that we run on a periodic
basis-- and you could run
this in a Cloud Function,
you could run this
in App Engine,
you could just run this on a
VM if you're not familiar with
those services--
and what that code does
is it will go reach out
to Cloud Security Command
Center and will say, give me
a list of all of my
resources, all of my assets,
that are security
level restricted.
And if any of them have
kind of unintended changes,
like say the bucket ACL has been
changed in the past 10 minutes
or 24 hours, create a finding.
Create a finding on that asset
and Security Command Center
so that the incident response
team can go and take a look
at that and kind of fix it.
So I'll show you
a simple demo now.
We'll switch over to the demo.
Awesome.
So I've got this bucket
here called Next 18 Demo,
and you can see on the--
can everyone see that
or should I zoom in?
I'll zoom in a little bit.
Right, so it's got a
security level of Restricted.
If I just dive into
it, you'll see here,
it's marked as restricted.
And right now,
there's 14 findings.
Now I want to point out, we
hope to see more findings
if the demo is successful.
Those 14 are for me testing
it so that I could make
sure it worked for you all.
Right, so we've got that bucket.
It's got 14 findings right now.
And the thing we care
about is whether or not
the ACL has changed in whatever
time period we've defined.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to go over to the actual bucket
here, and in the console,
you can actually edit the
permissions of the bucket.
And this is how the access
control list on the bucket
gets controlled.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to add myself,
and I'm just going to
pick something random,
like, say, storage
legacy bucket owner.
Awesome.
So you can see I've added
myself to the bucket ACL,
so the ACL should
have changed now.
And what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to just rescan all of our
assets in Cloud Security Command
Center.
This should take
about a minute or two.
So while this is
running, I'm just
going to walk you guys through
the code-- a little bit
of the code.
And today we're running this
on, like, an hourly basis,
but we could speed this
up if we wanted to.
And I guess it's
worth pointing out
that initially, Cloud
Security Command Center only
had a REST API exposed but
now there is a Python Client
Library, so for those of you
who are familiar with Python,
it's very simple to interact
with Security Command Center
and write some simple code that
interacts with it, basically.
Right, so I've got this method
here called checkChanges,
and this is a very simple.
All it's going to
do is it's going
to take a start time
of 15 minutes ago
and an end time of
now, and it's going
to say, in that 15-minute
window, get all of the assets
from Security Command
Center that have a security
level of restricted mark
on them, and if any of them
have changes that we care
about, create a finding, right?
So there's another method called
findChanges and this makes
a call out to Security Command
Center, get assets by mark.
So it's one of the API
methods you can use.
You can retrieve
all of the assets
from Security Command Center
that have a certain mark.
And of course for
different assets,
you're going to care about
different things, right?
For a bucket, we care about
the ACL and the owners
on the bucket, but for something
like an instance or a firewall,
you might care about
different properties.
So we just have a simple if
statement here that says,
for all of the assets that
come back, sort them by type,
and if it's a
bucket-- in this case,
it's the only one we're
checking in the demo--
we go into this method
here, bucketChanges.
And so what we then do
is we make another call
to Cloud Security Command Center
and we get the final asset.
So we have the
asset representation
at the beginning of
the 15-minute window
and then at the end of
the 15-minute window,
and we compare those two.
So here's the one we're
kind of interested in.
We say, if the
initial asset's ACL
is different than the
final asset's ACL,
then just call out to
Security Command Center
and create a finding that says
the bucket ACL has changed.
And I'll show you how simple
it is to actually create
that finding.
So that was all, like, kind of
my custom logic code and stuff.
This method here,
which is probably
about five lines of code, is
creating a finding in Cloud
Security Command Center.
So that's really
all you need, right?
We generate a unique
ID for the finding,
we specify the
category, we specify
the source, and an arbitrary
JSON blob of properties,
and then just the asset that we
want to create the finding on.
So in this case, it's a bucket.
So I'll actually
run the demo now.
We'll hope it works.
So it scaned through
a bunch of buckets,
and you can see there for the
Next 18 Demo bucket, which
is the one that I just
changed, it found two things
and it sent them to Cloud SCC.
So if we go back to
the console now--
and I'll just
update this to now--
we should see not
just 14 there, right?
So we can see now, there
are 16 findings, right?
So the default object ACL and
the bucket ACL both changed.
This was like 515 just
a couple of minutes ago.
And yeah, that's really it.
So what we do is we
basically run this code--
and we've extended it since then
to look at different things,
not just buckets
and their ACLs--
and we run this
just on a VM today
and it wakes up every so often,
runs, surfaces findings to us,
and then we react
to them, basically.
So we'll flip back
to the slides.
Awesome.
So I wanted to talk just a
little bit before I get off
stage about Cloud Security
Command Center and Forseti
and the integration
between the two.
So when we first got exposed
to these two services,
the way it worked is,
Forseti would basically
construct a list of
violations that it found based
on all the rules
that we had written
and it would push
these to a GCS bucket,
and then Cloud Security
Command Center would reach out
to that GCS bucket, it would
parse all of the violations,
and it would load
them into findings.
We thought this was
a little bit clunky.
It was the only thing
available at the time.
But then, one day Andy
and I were talking,
and the API for Cloud
Security Command Center
had been exposed,
and so we thought,
why not make this a
little bit better?
So what we did is we
worked kind of closely
with the Forseti and the Cloud
Security Command Center teams
and we modified that code
so that we use the Security
Command Center API directly.
So for any of you who
are using Forseti today,
you'll be familiar
with a YAML file
that you configure Forseti with.
You tell it, like, what
notifiers you want to run,
what rules you want
to run in the scanner.
There's a new section in where
you enable the Cloud Security
Command Center integration for.
You can now say either use the
bucket mode or the API mode.
And if you set it
to API mode, it's
going to use the API directly
rather than using that GCS
method of writing to a bucket.
And there was really
a couple reasons
why we wanted to do this.
One was obviously
it's just cleaner
to use the API
directly and not have
to rely on that latency of
writing something to GCS
and then waiting
for it to be read,
but the other reason is we
have a lot more control now
within the Forseti code base to
publish whatever properties we
want directly into that finding
in Cloud Security Command
Center.
So based on the rules that
your scanner is using,
you can write different property
fields into Cloud Security
Command Center.
All right, so that's it for me.
I have a wrapping up slide here.
Not much for me to talk
about, but really, I just
wanted to link to
the GitHub code base
there so you could see kind of
the integration between the two
services, and I encourage you
guys to play around with it.
So thank you and I'll invite
Kamilla from Cloudflare up now.
[APPLAUSE]
KAMILLA AMIROVA: One more time.
Hello, everyone.
I hope everyone
can hear me well.
Just give me a second.
All right.
So for those of you who haven't
heard about Cloudflare, which
is not a big surprise,
we are probably
one of the largest
internet companies
you might may be not aware of,
but you have used us today.
Everyone in this
room would have gone
to one of our millions websites,
properties, APIs, applications
that actually been protected
and accelerated by Cloudflare.
In fact, every single person
which uses internet today
touches our network every week.
Our mission is to build
a better internet.
So where are we today?
You can see it on
the slides that we
built a massive network.
We have over 150
data centers globally
and the number is growing.
More points of
presence means that we
create less latency for
websites and applications
and APIs to be
reached, but it's also
helped us to mitigate
really large attacks--
DDoS attacks.
We handle about 10%
of the global HTTP
traffic and our network capacity
about 15 terabits per second.
Currently, we actually have
about 8 million applications,
websites, and APIs that use us.
Well this slide helps you to
understand where Cloudflare
stands with Google Cloud.
We're not just partners.
Google is our investor.
As Cloudflare, we
refer to ourselves
as the edge network provider.
So those of you know,
what is actually edge?
Edge is where you meet the
business in the internet.
Originally, if you
might remember,
once you open your web browser
or application on your phone,
you are connected directly
to the service, which
is actually useful at business.
But we become extremely
demanding in terms
of performance, reliability,
and of course, security.
We expect, walking
down on the street,
having our phone with
us, order a taxi,
and almost immediately see
where is it on the map location.
We expect looking
down on the street
and FaceTime our parents or
families in high definition
and being actually
everywhere on the globe.
So in order to achieve
this, a new layer
has been introduced
in the internet.
This is what is called edge.
And this is where you are
connecting to business today
and this is where
Cloudflare sits.
Speaking about security
aspects and be efficient in it,
many companies facing
the following challenges.
Let's take, for example, a real
use case of a customer, which
is one of our customer's
online video platform
was running classes on
internet around the globe.
They have an infrastructure
which is using multiple clouds
and also something on premise.
Like, imagine to maintain
and manage the whole security
policy and security
aspects for all
that heavy sophisticated
environment.
The challenges, first of all,
is that it's all different tools
to use--
all the different interfaces.
And there are way
too many ways how
you can get that
information, but you
have to know each
tool separately
to avoid this
information by itself
or run a special script to
get that information gathered
in one place so you
can finally analyze it.
Or another case, in our case,
for example, our customers,
they see information that's
happening on their data centers
on the server, which is running
on, for example, Google Cloud
Platform, but also what's
happening on the edge.
But they don't have
an option where
to see that things
together and this
is where Google Cloud
Command Security Center plays
actually a very powerful role.
It is a simple
interface where you
are able within the
same unified dashboard
to see that data that come
in also from the edge and as
well as from your servers
that it's running on.
Cloudflare build an integration
with Cloud Security Command
Center to extend actually
security from data center all
the way to the edge.
And Cloudflare
dashboard-- actually,
Google Cloud Command
Security dashboard,
as you can see it here, being
populated with firewall--
web application firewall
and IP firewall events--
that actually are
running in real time that
help you to understand
what's happening right now
on the edge with your services.
So let's take a look at a
little bit of a solution in more
details and how it actually
works the integration itself.
The first step with going
through the Google Cloud
Platform [INAUDIBLE]
With a simple click of
a button, the customer,
like Two Sigma or
any other customer,
creates an instance
of App Engine.
And while it's created,
it also generates
a unique public key URL that
will be used on the Cloudflare
side to encrypt the data to send
them to Google Cloud Platform
App Engine API.
So all communication is
happening over [INAUDIBLE]..
So let's move on Cloudflare
side to see what's
happening on our edge.
This case, in
Cloudflare UI, customer
uses JavaScript, which is
run within the edge workers.
So now you ask me, what
is actually edge workers?
So while we're maintaining
security and performance
aspects for our
customers, Cloudflare
introduces an additional
functionality, Cloudflare Edge
Workers, which allows you to
run the code on the edge instead
of your server, which
immediately reveals
a powerful functionality and
web extensibility by moving
your logic from the server
all the way to the edge, which
means you can i A/B
testing now, you
can decide which traffic
you want to face it and test
it and load balancing
it, also improving user
experience that everything now
can run on the edge instead of,
like, creating that
latency to get the compute
and calculations on your
server and goes back and again.
So that's a huge,
huge, huge advantage.
So in this current
integration, you
can see these edge worker
acts like a proxy--
actually a very powerful proxy.
What it does is actually
connects [INAUDIBLE] API
to Cloudflare API to download
the logs, which is actually
gathered from all our 150 data
centers, and sends it back
to edge worker, where edge
worker encrypts this data
with public key that we
got generated in App Engine
instance and sends it to
Google Cloud Platform, where
App Engine instance gets this
data and posts it through
cloud SCC API to Cloud Command
Security Center dashboard.
So it runs quite fast.
And also very important that on
top of all that functionality,
we very care about security
point, and this is where--
very important--
both systems, they
won't expose their
sensitive data.
So a private API key
that's used by edge workers
to download the data
from Cloudflare edges
remains within the system,
as well as Google Cloud
data as well.
On top of that, we
have improved security
by allowing to lock requests
come into Cloudflare edge
only from Google ASN number.
Or you can also set
up rate limiting
so that you know that it has
that extra security levels.
All right.
Now let's dive into demo.
If you could switch
to the demo, please?
All right.
So I prepared a
small example here.
It's a website.
It's called usualwebsite.com.
In this case, we're going to
run it on the real use case.
Let's say I'm an
e-commerce site.
I'm actually selling
Argentinian wines.
Actually, I love
Malbec, so no secrets.
And I want to make
sure that I'm protected
and I'm benefiting from
performance and also
able to see everything
that's happening
both on data center and the
edge from security standpoint.
So let's switch to the
Google Cloud interface.
And this is where my website
is a simple WordPress site that
has actually been built on
App Engine that's running
on the demo target project.
That's where it actually
has been serving.
And as a separate project on
the security center API project,
I actually made an
installation on App Engine
that talks to
Cloudflare edge workers.
So now I'm going to
switch to Cloudflare UI
to get you to understand
what's happening here.
In Cloudflare UI, as well as
you're managing all your DNS
security performance
settings, you also
have here Workers section.
So I'm going to
launch an editor.
The way Cloudflare Workers
work is using actually
different JavaScripts.
So that's the JavaScript
that adapted for your needs
and using your own credentials.
You can see it here.
If you might recall,
the public URL
that's going to be
encrypted, that's
the one that's going to be used
by the worker and all you need
is just to keep the button
safe because it already has
that information filled out.
You can see it here.
Org ID, API key,
and everything just
stored within these
edge workers which
never leaves Cloudflare edge.
So once we push the
data, it actually
ends up in Security
Command Center,
and I'm going to
now a little bit
to make it small so that you can
see what's actually happening.
Within the dashboard,
as other companies,
we have a Cloudflare card
where you can see, let's say,
a quick glance of
statistics that's actually
happening on your edge.
You can see the top trend
origins, the percentage of them
as well, and you can
see the type of trends
we've been seeing, like a
firewall, IP rate limiting,
and what the last seen
events in the couple, let's
say, if it's minutes or hours--
something that hits our edge.
So if we want to look at
each of them in details,
we just click on the card or
we just click on the findings,
and on the
Cloudflare, we do have
a list of events that have been
captured and populated here.
So let's have a
look at one of them.
In this event, what
it can tell us--
it can tell us
that it's actually
IP rate limiting exceeded.
You can see actually
the asset ID--
which one's going to
be used in this case--
and scanner ID, which is
Cloudflare in this case.
When it happened
and the time stamp.
Very important,
that's something that
is very-- allows you in
Cloud Security Center
to go back in time so
you can look at-- you
can filter it up on
that request or events
that you are interested in.
It also helps you
to identify which VM
or which App Engine
or container it
is actually happening
on right now.
So let me find another
quick event that
can give you an idea of
what extra information
you can see here.
Yeah, I'm probably just
going to do it here.
Yeah.
For example, signal problem.
In this, it shows
you the organization,
it shows you the information
about what the request
method was, what the
hostname, the country,
and other external informations.
So if you want to
make any changes,
you still need to login
through the partner link
to Cloudflare UI, and
let's say block this IP
or block the country or
challenge it very easily.
All right.
That's actually all
for the demo and I'm
going to hand over
the talk to Francesco
from Palo Alto Networks.
[APPLAUSE]
FRANCESCO VIGO: I'm actually
starting with the demo.
It's not really the demo, but I
just got an email from a friend
and I wanted to start--
can you switch to Demo 2?
Yeah.
So I got this email about the
super fast bitcoin miner, which
sounds interesting, right?
So I want to actually start
mining right now on this cloud
machine so I can get rich.
Maybe I can pay for
some drinks later on.
So let me download this one.
Copy on the desktop.
Is the machine
running in the cloud?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANCESCO VIGO: We'll see.
I mean, let me try that.
I think it's a good idea, right?
To do this on the cloud, right?
So let's do it.
Oh.
OK, it's been blocked by
Traps, our endpoint protection.
So it wasn't a really good idea.
Unfortunately, nobody
is watching, right?
Nobody is recording, right?
My boss is not in the room?
Oh, he is.
OK, forget about that.
Let's switch to the
slides for a second.
So how many of you know
Palo Alto Networks?
OK, quite a few.
So our mission is
protecting the digital way
of life of our customers.
And I'm not explaining
exactly what
we do with all the
products and features,
but what we call security
operating platform is
a set of solutions running on
network as firewalls, endpoint,
cloud protection, virtual
firewalls running in the cloud,
and so on, but is meant
to successfully prevent
cyber attacks.
That's what we do.
And one of the reasons we
have been so successful
and we grew so much is
because we allow our customers
to consume innovation and
we allow our customers
to integrate our solutions
with their own solutions
and with third-party solutions.
That's very important.
The automation
integration for us
is really a key
part of our success.
And one of the things we
are working on right now,
which is not available
yet but will be soon,
is something that we call
Application Framework.
And again, I don't want to
get into too many details
so you can come to our booth
and ask questions to us,
but the point is,
many of our customers
have firewalls running
in their network,
are using our endpoint
protection solutions,
are using our cloud
are running virtual firewalls on
DCP, so for the customers that
want to do so, they can
actually send all the logs-- all
the data-- from these
devices, like security
logs, security-related
data, to our cloud.
And by doing that, they enable
us to run advanced analytics
on top of that.
So we have some solutions called
WildFire, Magnifier, and so
on that can actually
do threat intelligence,
do user behavior analytics
on top of the data
that our devices and endpoint
solutions put in the data lake.
And this has been
working for a while.
So with that framework, we are
adding something more on top
of that, which is providing
third parties a way--
so third parties means
partners, other vendors,
could be even competitors
if they want to do
so, and customers as well--
providing APIs to
access the data
that is present in the
application framework.
So as a customer,
if you consent so,
you can give access to
your security data that
was gathered from
Palo Alto Networks
and is stored in the
Palo Alto Networks cloud
to a third-party solution.
And through APIs, these
third-party solutions
can integrate and do analytics,
do integration, do treat intel.
There are lots of use cases.
And again, vendors and customers
will be able to do this.
And why we think
this is important.
We think that this is
important because if you
look at the security
consumption model,
how many security
vendors are out there?
A lot.
And each single security vendor
provides some unique value
to customers.
The problem is that
if you want to try
one of those vendors,
one of those solutions,
or if you just want to build
a solution because you are
a vendor and you want to build
a solution that does analytics,
for example, you will need to
deploy sensors, deploy agents
as a customer, and
as a vendor, you
need to write
sensors, write agents,
but your core business is
really analytics, maybe,
or threat intel.
You don't really need
to build that stuff
but you need that in
order for your customers
to consume your
unique value, right?
And for customers, it's
painful to do these POCs.
They are long and complex.
The other problem
is that if you have
lots of security solutions, you
have to deploy lots of things.
Infrastructure costs, operations
costs, is hard to manage.
And lastly, integrating all of
these different data sources
and providing an effective
automation workflow that
protects the customer is hard.
So with something like
application framework,
we want to be the
sensors and enforcer
in the network in the
endpoint in the cloud
and allow, again, third parties
and customers to leverage
our data to do analytics.
So if you want to try
a third-party solution,
you can just grant them access
to your data as a customer
and they're ready to go.
If you're a vendor and you
want to build a solution that
integrates with
that framework, you
don't need to deploy and
create sensors and agents.
You just call our APIs.
So these are very
effective and you
don't need to reinvest or
reinvent the wheel every time.
And the automation
capabilities that we can bring
there are very interesting.
In fact, when we
started working on this,
we were thinking
about some use cases,
and the more we worked
with different partners
and different customers, we
learned additional use cases
that we didn't even think about.
So that's really exciting.
So this is what we're
doing right now.
And back to the Security Command
Center integration point--
no, sorry, back to the slides.
OK.
So what we did is
building an integration
between the application
framework and the Security
Command Center.
It's a simple application.
We build it using
serverless components.
We used the Python SDK as well.
That was pretty easy to do.
And the idea is that
the data is coming
from Traps, our
endpoint solution,
from the firewalls
running in GCP.
All this data is flowing
in application framework.
And from there, the
Security Command Center app
is able to pick the data
up and generate findings
into Security Command Center.
And through some
user interface, you
can actually enrich those
findings with PI data.
You can act upon
that data, providing
blocking and remediation
in the firewalls.
Potentially enable
third-party integrations
on top of that as well.
So this will become
clear in a second.
So what we are doing right
now is showing this flow.
So, on the bottom,
you have an endpoint,
which actually is
the machine when
I try to bitcoin mine,
that had a malware that
was blocked by our
endpoint protection traps.
And the logs are being
sent from the endpoint
to application framework.
This will actually
be stored there
and the Security
Command Center app
that we wrote would
pick up this data,
detect that there is an
alert, and create a finding
in Security Command Center.
So we will see a finding
there, hopefully.
And from there, we will open
another console that we wrote
again for the purpose of this
integration-- very simple--
where we can do
additional analytics,
look at additional data,
and reach that alert
with threat intel
information that we have
and eventually block
the associated command
and control IP addresses
on the firewalls.
So protecting the other machines
that are running in the cloud.
And if, for some reason, there
is some machine that actually
has been infected
by that malware
because maybe my colleague
wasn't that smart
and he didn't
install traps on it,
the firewall will now
block it and will tell us
that something is going on,
and we'll see additional alerts
in Security Command Center.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANCESCO VIGO: You can do--
so the question is, can you
do the enrichment before
creating the alert?
Yes, you could.
So the idea is, we are doing
that manually, so as a security
analyst, I decide that I want to
enrich the data because I think
that this is an important
alert that I want to enrich,
but obviously you could
change the workflow
and automate that and add
threat intel before creating
the alert.
So let me go through the demo.
OK, thank you.
So this is the dashboard.
There are two alerts.
Now I refresh and
I see three alerts,
which means that
it's working, which
is wonderful because this is
an alpha product from Google.
It's a staging environment
alpha for us as well
and our DevOps teams did
some deployment today.
So I'm lucky.
So if I look at the
details of the finding,
you will see that we
have some stuff in here,
and one is called
Traps WildFire Malware.
So this specific
finding was generated--
you see on top-- eight minutes
ago and it actually tried
to block--
I mean, I tried to
run the bitcoin miner
and that was blocked by Traps.
And I have lots of
information here--
the user that did
this, Francesco.
The IP address of the
machine that generated that.
The malware hash.
And something
interesting also is
that this is linked to
an asset in Google Cloud.
And this is important because
Traps doesn't know anything
about the fact that that's
an asset from Google Cloud.
It just knows the IP address.
And we used actually the
API provided by the Security
Command Center to ask,
in our organization,
which machine had this IP
address at this point in time
when this event happened?
And their API said winsrv1.
Good, so we add it here.
So this is the
event as we see it.
And now I can open
the partner console,
which is again a simple
application that we wrote.
Right now I'm pulling
additional traffic and threat
logs related to that machine
from the application framework.
So I have firewall
logs and other stuff
that I can pull
and visualize here.
And again, I don't want to
get into too many details,
but one of the things
that it can do is--
this is suspicious, right?
So let's see if Palo Alto
Networks knows some threat
intel about this, a
specific piece of malware.
So when I click on
Auto-Focus, I'm calling again
our Cloud APIs and I'm pulling
threat intel information
from our cloud.
And if you see these tags--
well, I'm not getting into the
details of which one of that
means, but basically,
it's telling me
that this is a specific
piece of malware that
is part of a specific
campaign and there
are some IP addresses and
a few [INAUDIBLE] that
are associated to this
specific piece of malware.
I would probably
want to block this.
Before I do that, let me switch
back to the Security Command
Center Console.
So by doing that, we actually
added those Auto-Focus tags
marks in the security event.
So this means that even
if I don't have access
to the other console--
I just have access to
Security Command Center--
the fact that myself as an
analyst did that enrichment,
this information
becomes available also
to my colleagues when they
look at this specific finding.
So back to our console.
I want to block this.
I want to block the associated
command and control IP address.
So what I'm going to do
is just click on Block,
but before doing that, let me
switch over to the firewall.
Again, I don't want to get into
the details on how this works,
but this is our
firewall running in GCP.
I created the policy that will
block all the IP addresses that
are part of a specific
Dynamic Address Group, or DAG,
and right now, this
group is empty.
So there is nothing there.
If I go back to my UI
and click on Block,
through application
framework, we
are telling the firewall,
OK, from now on, you
should block the command
and control IP address
associated to this malware.
So if I'm lucky--
and get back here, OK.
You see in the firewall, that
IP address is now being blocked.
And this information
again is also
reflected in here--
in Security Command
Center-- as an additional mark.
So again, as a fellow
analyst, I can look into this
and say, OK, someone
took care of this.
This should be good enough.
So I can actually do our solve
here, saying, OK, this incident
has been taken care of.
So I'll just click Resolve.
And if I go back to
Security Command Center,
this will now disappear.
Why?
Because this would
be marked as Resolved
and I have a filter
here that is showing
only the alerts and the
findings that are not resolved.
So one last thing I
wanted to show you
is that now that I actually
set the block on the firewall,
I might want to see if there
is other activity related
to that specific command and
control for that malware.
And actually there
is, so my colleague
has a machine that
is actually trying
to connect to that
command and control
and that was blocked now.
And this is again something
that I can see on the firewall
but also through the integration
with application framework.
This might take a few
seconds to show up,
because again, the log is going
through application framework
and the application
that we wrote
is pulling the data from
application framework
and generating the finding
in Security Command Center.
So let's wait a few
seconds, if we have them.
I mean, the last bit of the last
demo of the last presentation
of the day.
Obviously there is
some suspense, right?
Here we go.
So C2 traffic blocked.
Again, this is another machine.
This alert is still coming
from application framework
but originally has been
created by the firewall,
not by the endpoint agent,
but the user experience
is exactly the same.
And we have different user
and other information.
So the previous incident
has been resolved,
but I have another
incident I should work on.
So that's all it
had for the demo.
Let's go back to the slides
one more time, please.
Thank you.
So takeaways.
First of all, it was fun
and easy to integrate
with Security Command Center.
We had a great--
again, Python
libraries were easy,
serverless was pretty
good to work with,
and Andy was great
in supporting us.
And the other takeaway is that,
with application framework,
we encourage vendors,
competitors, customers
to come to us, talk to us,
and build applications that
can leverage the data
we provide in order
to provide value to yourselves
or to your customers.
Please reach out to us,
because again, you can easily
get access through the
Palo Alto Networks data
if your customers allow
you to do so, of course.
And with this
specific integration,
we were able to build a
simple single pane of glass
to do Security Command Center.
So that's all I've got.
I'm inviting Andy back
on stage for the wrap-up.
Thank you.
ANDY CHANG: Thanks, Francesco.
So thank you so much.
First, I think first
give a round of applause
to all the speakers
who did live demos.
We were four for four, so a
little bit of bravery there.
I think to quickly
wrap up, because I
know we're towards the end of
the day, some key questions
that Cloud Security
Command Center has
helped answer for customers
are around the assets.
The fundamental question
is, what do I have?
What am I running?
I think our experience has been
that with the shadow IT that
develops around cloud,
we actually provide
this visibility to customers.
Customers have sometimes
been very surprised.
The average amount our
customers are off was about 25%.
Some customers were off
by a factor of three
as to how many assets they
were actually running in cloud.
So that core visibility
is one of the first things
they gain from this.
As we saw with Two Sigma,
Cloudflare, and Palo Alto,
the ability to
integrate findings
from a lot of different
places to get really
at things that are going
wrong, potential risk
and vulnerabilities
in the cloud,
has another been a huge win.
Now, in addition, with our own
detectors and Cloud Anomaly
Detection, the security
scanning, and the DLP,
it's given further
visibility to our customers
as to what's going
on their systems
around the finding pieces.
And as you can
see from the slide
and going back to the original
slide about what we're building
Command Center to try
to help you detect,
it's issues around your
inventory, around your config,
around access, around data,
and around the underlying
applications you're running.
In the public alpha
release that we announced,
there are really five kind of
key things that are core of it
and we demoed most of
these things today.
The asset inventory pieces.
Today, we support five
of the Google services
in the asset inventory.
The analysis to pieces that
have been used to allow
you to find specific things.
The marking part.
What we didn't demo today are
kind of the notification piece
that's built in to how you can
use Command Center to generate
a Pub/Sub through a
Sidecar application
and also to directly trigger
actions through cloud functions
through a Sidecar application.
The create findings API that
each of our customers and two
partners have integrated with.
And really again going back to
that top goal of covering each
of the five different
things we're
looking for from a
security standpoint.
The ecosystem is starting
and continuously growing,
and we're going to add more
this quarter into the following
quarters, and we're hoping
that you folks in the audience,
whether you're a direct
customer who's writing findings
and wants your own detectors or
have specific partners that you
want to integrate,
come talk to us
and we can help prioritize that.
So to learn more, we had
a blog post back in March.
All of our documentation
is online and public.
That includes the underlying
documentation as well as
the API guides.
And so with that, I
want to thank you guys.
I want to invite the
other speakers back up.
And I think we have a few
minutes for questions,
but I also recognize that
we're keeping you from drinks,
so I'm certainly
cool if you guys just
want to call it a day.
But thank you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]